[Music]
pretty richmond virginia there
virginia's governor signed a bill
yesterday forbidding local public school
districts from requiring students to
wear masks the law will go into effect
march first after republicans teamed up
with a handful of democrats to pass it
it lets parents decide whether or not to
have their children wear a mask in
school
parents in several virginia districts
have sued in opposition trying to force
the state to keep mass decisions in the
hands of local school boards
governor glenn younkin joins us now
governor good morning thank you for
being here i saw the ceremony yesterday
it was clearly a big deal moment for you
there in virginia i'm hoping you could
start by just walking us through how you
came to this decision at this moment at
this time
well it was it was a big moment for
parents and kids in virginia yesterday
and i was just very honored to be
partnering with democrats and
republicans in our legislature in order
to sign that bill you know what this
bill and now into law reflects is the
fact that parents are best decision are
best positioned to make these decisions
for their kids
what we said yesterday is that if
parents want their children to wear a
mask then they should absolutely be able
to do so and if they think the best
thing for their child is not to wear a
mask then they should be able to make
that decision as well it was a big day
for parents a big day for kids
and a big day for virginia yesterday
now governor in theory parents already
have the power to make decisions for
their local schools through their school
boards
what was the issue that you saw with
that process
well the reality of course is that
school boards are elected over an
extended period of time
and what we've seen over and over
particularly in virginia over the last
couple years
is that school boards are out of touch a
bit with parents and and so what this
what this law now clearly reaffirms
is what already is in virginia law that
parents have a fundamental right to make
decisions with regards to their
children's upbringing their education
and their care
and this was an important this is an
important bill turning into law for us
to reaffirm those rights and so virginia
parents now can make these decisions yes
they can make a decision for their child
to wear a mask if that's in their
child's best best uh best health
decision or they can make a decision for
their child not to wear a mask you know
this is this is about putting power back
into the hands of the people and this is
also about getting back to normal and
we're on the path to get back to normal
in virginia and that's why today is a
very big day for virginians
yeah a lot of people agree with that
they want to get back to normal there is
a portion of the population looking at
the positivity rate there in virginia
it's a above 10 percent for covet tests
i'm curious you have power still in this
law to take action if needed are you
looking at any particular benchmarks and
conversation with public health
officials or experts in your state about
when you might take action to maybe
reinstate a mandate or require masks in
school
well i have i have a spectacular medical
advisory board that i've been working
with for a long time and i speak with
the leadership across virginia from our
hospital association
frequently and of course our own vdh
virginia department of health and what
we've seen of course is omicron fall off
materially is far less severe and we're
seeing a lot of the pressure in our
hospital system in fact be relieved this
is the moment also for us to to laud and
appreciate and thank the hospital
workers across virginia and across the
nation for all that they do in order to
keep everybody safe we're on the back
end of omicron and i'm excited about
that i think that we need to continue to
recognize that that this pandemic
and kobit 19 aren't going to go away but
it is absolutely far less severe and we
have a path to get back to normal and
that's that's the path we're going to be
on in virginia
yeah governor i you know would be a
pioneering move if you were to publish
benchmarks that you were using to make
your decision so i am curious in our
final question here if if you would do
that and then the second quick question
is do you encourage parents to get their
kids vaccinated
well i encourage everyone to get
vaccinated but i also want people to
make that decision on their own
and again we won't mandate it but we in
fact launched a public service
announcement this past week in order to
strongly encourage people to get
vaccinated we know it's the best way to
protect yourself protect your family and
so we in fact had a great meeting this
past week in petersburg we had a great
meeting this past week in petersburg in
order to really work with uh the
people's community in order to get
people more governor we're gonna they're
gonna they're gonna take us to black
it's your first appearance on cbs
mornings it will not be your last we
appreciate you being here
i got to go to break though thank you
very much
governor glenn young thank you we'll be
right back have a great day